alors on pas si on peut parler du front
national ce qu'on a vu c'est que c'est
un parti qui ne devrait jamais existé
tout simplement on devrait on ne devrait
pas pouvoir voter pour quelqu'un qui
fait partie du front national pourquoi
il ya pour des suisses âgées assimilent
le pour moi le front national c'est
comme des nazis pour moi pour moi je
vois comme ça donc je trouve pas ça
normal qu'on puisse voter pour des nazis
peut pas y avoir un parti nazi et l'easa
l'allant qui dit rien salamé est les
intervieweuses comme moi jamais c'est
pourquoi les noirs mais bon on a besoin
d'une contradiction je suis pas d'accord
avec jean michel sur plein de trucs et
on en discute sur france inter la
contradiction vous allez là bas ça c'est
sûr que sur france inter la
contradiction va pas longtemps de ça
c'est sûr sur france inter le seul truc
qui est bien c'est qu'il ya pas de pub
les chéris il n'y a pas de booba qui
sont des prix au rassemblement national
ces dernières heures il ya aussi
christophe castaner qui hier a déclaré
de s'ajuster d'un parti raciste mais il
était sur france info c'est l'autre
succursales en même si aujourd'hui
marine le pen a mis des atours
différence des guise de façon différente
elle reste ce qu'elle est celle qui lie
à 10 en danse et en autriche avec des
nains si c'est ça la réalité est
nécessaire de ne jamais oublier que le
front national est un parti multi
condamné que c'est un parti raciste que
c'est un parti qui était condamnée aussi
pour antisémitisme et que c'est un parti
qui au fond aujourd'hui et plus financés
par l'étranger et plus dépendants de
l'étranger que n'importe quel autre
parti dans notre pays alors justement on
ouvre le débat soit parce que c'était
très redondant sur les réseaux sociaux
ce matin c'est vrai que tout le monde en
a parlé il ya des manic simone de nom et
gilles verdez nous dit oui oui il faut
dire les choses ici je parle pas du tout
les oppose donc diriger le parti en tant
qu'organisation lra si je suis d'accord
avec ce qui est dit c'est un parti qui
discrimine c'est un parti qui
hiérarchise les gens en fonction de là
d'où ils viennent
c'est un parti qui fustige l'immigration
c'est un parti qui souvent tape fort sur
les mains et les menteurs
c'est la définition pour moi de partir à
si je réponds oui sans ambages continue
sa série et jean mathia il dit pas que
des bêtises
ainsi il est des bêtises on sait déjà qu
est-ce que c'est la définition du
racisme
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on prenne sa
l'état premier le mot réseau la vôtre a
en gros le racisme c'est considérer
qu'il existe des différences entre les
races et par rapport à ça faire une
échelle 2d degré de perfection entre
chacune
nous on est humaniste moi je vois pas de
rasmané séculière serre moi je vois des
êtres humains en face de moi moi je peux
avoir quelqu'un originaire d'afrique du
nord gr d'asie originaire de n'importe
quel pays je vois un être humain je vais
pas regarder quand on dit le programme
du rassemblement national il ya quand
même des discriminations alors vous
allez me dire ou parce que dans notre
programme je suis désolé on n'est jamais
tombé dans le piège du racialisme que
veulent me tendre à chaque fois nos
adversaires jamais une seule fois on a
toujours défendu qu'un être humain est
un être humain
on n'a jamais laissé entendre qu'ils
pourraient faire des différences entre
les uns et les autres et on a toujours
prôné le respect de la laïcité
donc je veux dire on est vraiment
exemplaire là dessus c'est pour ça que
je suis même étonné de voir toutes ces
diffamations qui sont faites à
l'encontre de notre parti qui est un
parti tous les plus républicains
aujourd'hui ce parti il monte tout
simplement il fait peur parce qu'il dit
des vérités et parce qu'on dérange si on
essaye de ressortir à chaque fois ce
spectre du nazisme mais je crois que
tous ces gens là ne savent plus ce que
c'était le nazisme en r&d attaché mais
tout simplement enfin vous êtes en train
de dire ok pour vous les français sont
les mêmes d'où qu'ils viennent et c'est
jeudi les êtres humains non mais on va
le français vous êtes vous êtes
humaniste la france s'inquiète de savoir
si elle va avoir assez de jeunes non
pour cotiser pour sa retraite pour
pourquoi vous voulez absolument donner
de l'argent aux gens pour qu'ils fassent
des enfants ça vous fait tellement peur
qu'ils aient des gens qui viennent de
l'étranger
ouais c'est vraiment vous fait pas de
différence mairie mais l'argent mais moi
je sais toi tu veux pas qu'elle gens qui
viennent de l'étranger n'ont jamais mais
si mais si on fait péter la revanche
contre les français en fonction de la
wii viennent waouh lait subventionné
comme ça absolument des femmes reste à
la maison pour qu'elle fasse des enfants
en fait vous savez que ce pays peut pas
vous laisser
ce pays il va avoir besoin de la
jeunesse va avoir besoin parce qu'on n'a
plus assez de jeunes pour financer les
retraites et autres et vous vous
acharnez c'est marqué dans votre
programme on est prêt à tout faire pour
des femmes reste à la maison et pas des
enfants des femmes blanches française
vous avez dit juste marine le pen arrive
il ya peu de temps à l'afp l'un d'eux
télé pour dire effectivement moi je
donne à ce qu'ils restent chez eux aux
falaises blanches ou maman non non vous
ne voulez vous ne mettez pas tous les
français sur la même échelle
ainsi vous pour vous les français les
français de papier où les français qui
sont pas de papiers comme la niveau de
sénateurs de marseille stéphane ravier
c'est pas la même chose quand on a parlé
de la chanson du souffre à quand on a
parlé de l'hymne de france et ses
chances et de papier ne seront jamais
des vrais français jusque souffre a
d'ailleurs je me suis déjà exprimé sur
cette question déjà je comprends pas
pourquoi on choisit cet artiste là
pourquoi on l'aimé bien pourquoi pas
quand quand on voit les paroles qu'il
dit à la fois sur la france sur les
femmes sur les blancs géré je m'étonne
si vous voulez que que toute la sphère
progressiste souffre à ce qu'ils
appellent en permanence à protéger à
protéger et la police et les femmes ne
pas rentrer dans le racisme
il encourage finalement un artiste alors
je comprends que parce que il est de
couleur il a le droit de tout dire on
imagine un artiste blanc qui aurait été
la même chose ce serait ou non parce que
là en l'occurrence ou face à un rappeur
très populaire mais pour en revenir à ce
que disait aurélien taché et l'instant
moi j'ai un truc que je veux avec lequel
je suis pas d'accord avec toi c'est que
tu vois les êtres humains cher aurélien
ne sont pas des êtres interchangeables
on ne peut pas dire il manque 2 millions
de français
qu'à cela ne tienne on va les remplacer
par des millions d'africains ça se passe
pas comme ça en noir les nations et les
nations laonnois ans et par une question
haleine les nations ont une identité
aucun peuple au monde n'accepterait cela
les nations ont une identité nationale
un être humain c'est aussi une
appartenance à une culture ce sont des
racines on peut pas raisonner sur des
êtres humains comme si c'était des
marchands de l'ordre
hormis et cultures sur pied juste et
justes et justin dernier moment quand
jean dont ces gens voulaient en france
pour être français
mais non parce qu on a on a fait déjà
avec que les gens qui souhaitent qu'ils
sont déjà en france soit français nés
avant de vouloir faire importer des gens
vont se dire alors je dis simplement que
les déclarations de deux de cet abruti
brutale de deux castaner et de oui-oui
télé de i read et d'un rappeur qui est
un qi d'écrevisses ciment mais il est
très intelligent il n'hésita pas des
bombes et les décors l'islâm
independence ave c'est pour vous dire un
truc ils restent sur 7 et 10 janvier ce
que je crois genre vincent le front
national n'aime pas ces racistes pour
tuer reste ya pacte est encore plus
quand même pas pu rester si c'était
passé à 80 à 100 pour cent vingt ans
l'école laboute vichy appelé les
résistants les terrorismes aujourd'hui
les collabos de la colonisation de la
france appelle les résistants des
terroristes alors vous nous appelez pas
des terroristes vous nous appelez des
dairas france qui dit non vous n'avez
déracinés pour que la france accueille
des gens comme toi là tu n'attends
européens ils étaient résistants alors
moi je sais je la vois les gens vous
devriez parmi les dix mois je sais que
ce qui est souvent accusée et d'ailleurs
c'était d'ailleurs boubala mobiliser
c'est à dire les nazis moi je vais vous
dire un truc c'est que l'on reproche
effectivement beaucoup au rassemblement
national vichy etc
mais attendez mais l'histoire récente
enfin qui s'est rendu coupable des
massacres de sétif et de guelma en 45 ce
n'est pas le général de gaulle qui a
fait la guerre d'algérie dont on nous
dit que c'est un crime contre l'humanité
c'était pas un centriste et de gâteaux
avec dell dernière fois alors n'était
pas volé le socialiste vous arrêtez pas
le général de gaulle qui enfin on en
parle on peut encore aujourd'hui
beaucoup qui avait qui a aidé au
génocide dans le rwanda s'étaient pas un
président socialiste qui s'appelle
mitterrand alors je vais vous dire si
vous voulez ouvrir le passé nous en gt2
la ruche que tous ces gens là dans mon
passé je vais vous dire un truc vous
ferez mieux de vous faire discret parce
que vu les atrocités que la gauche et la
droite ont contribué à faire à travers
le monde
je me ferai dit c'est sûr que j'aimerais
qu'on écoute la nasse le ratio national
est il un parti raciste pour vous anas
et oui moi je vais les réconcilier déjà
je pense que le rassemblement national
comme castanet
en tout les deux raciste la réalité
c'est que déjà le front national c'est
ça son son histoire c'est la fondation
notamment avec léon gautier qui était un
venez c'est ce qu'a fondé le front
national
on essaie de dédiabolisant dix ans mais
souhaitait c'était son père jean marie
le pen marine le pen à l'airé elle était
porte-parole de la campagne de
jean-marie le pen si elle était
condamnée justement pour toutes les
atrocités qu'il a dit autour notamment
de delachaux à ces menaces a même été le
président d'honneur jean messia il
lui-même il s'étonne par exemple des
livreurs de hubert pendant le ramadan
parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à 21h le
moment du ramadan en fait il n'a pas son
sandwich et et du coup ça ça hyper locle
à ce moment là il ya des ennemis il ya
des immigrés qui les intéressent mais
au-delà de ça le rassemblement national
le c'est un parti qui est profondément
raciste xénophobe mais c'est aussi un
parti qui est profondément anti ouvrière
en fait c'est un parti qui en fait
méprise les prolétaires méprise les
petites gens méprisent des gens qui sont
au quotidien sont en train de lutter moi
tout ce matin j'étais aux côtés des
égoutiers des éboueurs de la ville de
paris qui luttent justement contre la
réforme de du de de la fonction publique
j'ai des camarades de l'infra paul de
paris nord qui sont en grève depuis
quatre mois
il ya des mecs de picardie il ya des
mecs qui viennent du fin fond de du 19e
arrondissement guyancourt il ya des
noirs des arabes des blancs et militent
ensemble isbat ensemble depuis plus de
quatre mois
c'est ça la réalité en fait que nous on
voit au quotidien le problème c'est que
quand on a marine le pen va dire que le
smic horaire ses 36 euros ils sont dans
plein de magouilles on le voit encore
aujourd'hui sur les histoires
d'assistants parlementaires européens la
réalité c'est que le rassemblement
national
il est ce ce caractère là mais il faut
pas oublier castaner parce que castaner
c'est aussi les bornes your de gilet
jaune c'est celui qui a fait une
politique ultra répressif c'est celui
qui a mis en place notamment les
prémices de la loi séparatisme soit au
moment de l'agression de l'islam aux
séries mais moi je n'irai pas en fait
castaner qui est rien que la la la la
prière appuyer ou renforcée pendant le
ramadan que celui qui jeûne pendant le
ramadan c'est des signes de radicalité
et la réalité c'est que ces gens-là et
jean messia je suis je peux je partage
qui viennent dire en renvoyant la
l'histoire de de gaulle et mitterrand
etc
c'est que la réalité c'est que la
bourgeoisie de manière générale elle a
toujours été profondément raciste et
bien sûr le rassemblement national c'est
l'extrême droite
le secteur low cost ryanair guillaume
genton il est quand même le livre le
nommer on retrouve là et rationnelle et
quand même beaucoup moins raciste parce
qu'il a tué personne je remercie on
appelle vous entend pas aussi quitter le
pays il nous entend jamais non plus
pragmatique et quand même des millions
de français vont finir il rassemble et
qui sont pas racistes pour autant de
chances que c'est un peu un cliché est
un raccourci peut-être qui date de
l'époque du front national mais tout le
parti a quand même un peu évolué il ya
peut-être des racistes rassemblement
national mais aussi des racistes dans
d'autres partis pourquoi leurs acides
note attribuée à un seul parti politique
c'est différent un parti politique est
raciste
non mais la foule assemblée mensuelle
est raciste lui des gens que des mêmes
des ouvriers qui vaudra semblement
nationale c'est indéniable oui il ya des
gens qui comme moi j'ai des collègues
autour de moi qu'il ya déjà il ya des
collègues autour de moi qui sont les
nids qui sont pris parfois parle envie
de se dire je vais voter rassemblement
national mais jamais par rapport à
l'idéologie nazie et coller au
rassemblement national c'est la question
du chaos danse et pour fixer à noir
d'encre pour essayer de mettre un grand
coup d'arrêt dans la nature mais moi ces
gens là je leur dis mais réveillez vous
en faites penser que vous aussi pour le
rassemblement national un parti qui
rompt le père en fille en fête de
génération en génération se refilent le
pouvoir dans lequel il ya des énarques à
des gens qui n'ont jamais travaillé de
l'un des rares qui t'explique que sais
tu n'as qu'à rien qu'à fermer world
poule qui t'explique que c'est mamadou
qui a fermé ford blanquefort qui est
expliqué khadija qui a fermé bridgestone
et 800 emplois en fait ils vont aller
chercher la misère ils vont aller
essayer de récupérer la misère en disant
regarde tu as vu l'arabe là bas ça cause
de lui que ahmad encore s'ils vont me
laisser les autres ils sont toujours de
leur côté en dernière instance et au
premier en suisse elle répond non mais
attends c'est vrai aujourd'hui alors tu
en face de toi fais tu pour défendre le
rassemblement
alors je vais devenir lénine mais elle a
des racines
il ya des présidents à jaca des
présidents mossi noir qui ont été
raciste alors pas lutter contre la pole
à lutter contre nous je lui
conseillerais aux contrevenants qui le
voit justement parce que l'histoire à
l'histoire elle a parlé les discours
quand le front national parce que moi je
l'appelle toujours le front national
c'est pas parce que tu change le nom
c'est les discours qu'ils ont sont
toujours les mêmes marié moi je rejoins
and haas en fait ici sorte sur le fait
que comme les raiders ça s'appelle tweet
mme amélie sort sur le fait
c'est l'exemple 600 sur le fait des mm50
comme il ya de la misère alors ils te
disent que oui parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui travaillent pas alors ils
touchent des aides alors sa cause de sa
cause de cas du bordel d'or etc etc
mais moi je suis issu de l'immigration
je peux pas et je peux pas être pour le
front national c'est pas possible après
je dis je persiste et signe
ça reste quand même le premier parti de
france et s'il n'y a pas tout ces
alliances à chaque fois non mais là ils
sont inutiles sont bidons mais la
question pour vous c'est à partir à sem
même n'a obligé de dire maintenant quand
on entend parler jean médias qui s'en
prend à youssoupha qu'est ce qui lie
youssoupha qui dérange pourquoi il dit
mais je m'en prends pas youssouf a passé
quinze jours il vous donne à manger
aujourd'hui quand vous venez sur les
plaques à youssouf mais là quand vous
venez monsieur messier avait personne
qui nous fait il le fait un tunisien
qu'il fait oublier jamais s'arrêter
ceinture même niveau de commerce de jean
médias pour les origines droit on invite
jean messia dans l'ensemble des plateaux
de télé de france et de navarre il passe
seul a vu dans les vtc contador je le
zappe sur les chaînes je tombe sur ces
nuls vierges en lice hier qu'elle passe
à sonia mabrouk il est là j'aimerais
enfin m j'ai vu j'ai vu dans un crédit à
ryadh à granby
sincèrement il vit dans les bêtas c'est
ouais j'ai pu tenter pourquoi pourquoi
nous disons bienvenue je vis dans un
message au japon est importé 2 en dvd et
ses attentes et je suis d'offres je vis
dans des vpc mois dernier par français
requis chômage est temps de mon
téléphone pour qu'ils entrent l'adresse
[Musique]
et tous les dossiers où la demande et
moi ce que je vais gérer des jarres
essai raté c'est à ces messages violents
socialiste a avoué je laisse à la mode
est à vous qui êtes à grands pas durer
la société c'est pas pour moi je ne suis
pas la marque et son pré carré qui
essayent de vianney boyfriend palais
l'art est un défi céréales et galatée
juste un mot la réalité c'est que j'en
ai cher pourquoi il a invité sa les deux
choses où les personnes comme jean
messia comme sonia mabrouk et les audi
sont invités parce que notamment d'être
isolement régime qui sont vie qui est
visé et que sacré vous étiez vous
enlevez non je joue bien et si je
voudrais désir des gens mais cela est
montré dans les villes
quand je dis les gars c'est moi tout ça
c'est des gens mais ça oui sur place à
la salle alec quand on est pas sûr que
les quatre allers vers si vous souhaitez
pas vous sortez vous nous faites chier
il est batteur accès pour paraître
dégagée passé à bercy bâtiment fin du
débat mais seulement michel drucker a
fait sortir tout va mais je vous dis il
reste deux minutes
si vous parlez pas les uns après les
autres vous sortez un jeu vous dire
voilà regarder cyril j'aimerais savoir
si je peux terminer avant 3 ou convient
aussi jean merci à si vous lui enlevez
immigration islam immigration islam il
n'a invité donc un plateau on va pas
l'invitant va on s'en fout de savoir ce
que messi a inséré mars dollar à chauny
savoir ce que messi à pense de
l'économie à chaque fois qu'on a fait
c'est parce qu'il ya une histoire de
drogue via une histoire de quartier il
ya une histoire dit cela via une
histoire de l'immigration c'est tout le
temps la même et je vous le dis si vous
ne parlez pas d'immigration si vous
parlez pas dit cela parce que les
personnes qui aimeraient de
l'immigration passe mais l'immigration
et l'islam et sortent une veine
jugulaire s'y inquiète beaucoup de
français à prévenir les millions vous
n'êtes pas de la menace et à 11 millions
de personnes qui ont voté aux pour le la
candidate du rassemblement national en
2010 est celle que voulait berne et moi
je voudrais pas vous répondre à vous
vous avez raison les gens qui votent
front national sont pas tous racistes
sont pas tous m'a bien sûr c'est ce
parti qui est raciste il n'y a pas une
semaine dans ce dans ce qu'on regarde
l'actualité on regarde les journaux il
ya une semaine il ya par leur candidat
qui est obligé d'être ville front
national n'importe où vous avez toujours
un gars qui fait un truc pour dire les
bouts nous les [ __ ] les machins vous
avez ça dans votre parti si dans votre
parti c'est pas dans les autres villes
dinars et votre site
oui s'ils n'étaient pas toujours la même
question posée pourquoi vous êtes parti
si c'était aussi bien son fils cyril
seguy j'ai été sur ce plateau
j'ai été amené à critiquer parfois
durement marine le pen le rassemblement
national etc
je suis pas là pour défendre marine le
pen elle est assez grande pour le faire
je suis là pour rétablir une certaine
vérité il
trouve qu'effectivement j'ai eu un
parcours de 4 années au rassemblement
national moi qui suis arrivé en france à
l'âge de 8 ans qui était naturalisé à 20
ans je n'ai jamais au rassemblement
national éprouver le moindre racisme de
qui que ce soit j'en ai même été l'un
des cadres les plus importants gsm et y
langues nationales du rassemblement la
salive et renouvelé voulons faire et ses
récits se déplacer
ça n'est pas un des pins il apparaissait
très bien pas dit c'est très très bien
belle et des rassemblements la même si
ça trouve un catalan thierry guerrier il
a pris deux chercher il ya eu des
paquets dans libé imams n'ont plus
vraiment des gens il m'a dit monsieur
khadir est attendu à tous avec une photo
de pendaisons et c'est un des leviers du
rassemblement national
c'est ça la ga bühlmann et qu'on n'a pas
entendu là tu vous dites oui ou non vous
avez un délai jusqu'à la fin car non non
non je dis non non pour revenir
castetner ce qu'il a dit je trouve que
c'est un aveu d'incompétence et ridicule
bulls qui la disent et c'est dramatique
franchement c'est très grave parce que
comparer le rassemblement national
et dieu sait que je ne suis pas d'accord
avec ce parti à un parti nazi en fait
c'est désacraliser le troisième reich la
shoah mais je trouve que ces jeux
dramatiques est décidément voilà je
pense que si c'est votre ami vous
devriez lui dire et ensuite si si la
faiseuse pour montrer la gravité bien
suivant mais la raison big up à raison
d'avoir de rails quand il dit que le
pass and i ter excusez moi c'est
peut-être un symbole de l'étoile jaune
j'allais me sortir tous les soirs mais
affichent une étoile chez moi j'ai mon
univers à la manif
des trucs on s'emballe et si tu venais
les trucs des dix ans tué lors des
ateliers sur la page et nous lors de mon
dernier mot reste respectueux de minutes
mais je suis sur un nuage et à tous les
styles sont respectueux voilà genre
c'est insupportable
le ciridd à te plaît et eroglu sans
déconner non mais je te dit rôles où je
t'adore je t'ai vu chez procter n'est
pas parce que moi tu approches te dit tu
as well as déjà mis en jeu soit le
rassemblement national ont diabolisé ont
fait ça dans l'intimité renvoie pas ce
cas quid de la banque centrale ça
fonctionne même est ce qu'ils continuent
à augmenter son essai le siphonner comme
sarkozy ça n'a pas fonctionné non plus
parce que malgré tout pardon mais une
migration c'est pas un raciste pas
raciste que de parler d'immigration
parler de la violence policière
enfin de la viola violences contre les
policiers c'est pas d'être raciste ou
pas raciste parler de la précarité c'est
pas d'être un tueur mais l'allemagne
le rapport à tout ce qui a été dit a dit
on parle pas des candidats qui sont sur
des listes de gauche et écologistes et
qui sont connus pour leur soutien à
l'islam radical
on parle pas de la résurgence
progressive l'antisémitisme de gauche
qu'on voit qu'on observe de plus en plus
on parle du rassemblement national qui
soit disant serait pour la haute
bourgeoisie
moi je vous le dis je suis un chien
gamin de la rue moi j'ai grandi au
mirail cet argent j'ai fini aujourd'hui
cadres parce que j'ai travaillé pour ça
d'accord j'ai bénéficié de l'ascenseur
social que l'on a en france et moi le
rassemblement national ne m'a jamais
discriminés par rapport à mes origines
et merci à vis des conditions parler
d'antisémitisme d'être nazi
le démo ne sais quoi qu'ils aient
considéré que les chiffres sont des
ennemis de la nation est une sous race
au rassemblement national moi il ne m'a
jamais été dit que j'étais un ennemi de
la nation ou une sous race au contraire
au contraire on m'a donné la chance de
pouvoir exprimer mes idées politiques et
non pas pour la france cela je ne
remercierai jamais assez le
rassemblement national pour le fait de
m'avoir permis dans une représentation
politique pour le faire dit o'meara
castaldi qu'est ce qui dit non non moi
je dis non pas ce qu'ils veulent c'est
que plus on va dire que c'est en partie
rassuré lui plus d'un mois ils vont
pouvoir s'exprimer et déversé surfer sur
tout ce qu'ils savent faire depuis le
début à savoir l'islamophobie et pour
dire ah ça et plus vous aurez la parole
et plus malheureusement vous pourrez
vous l'exprimez donc effectivement
qu'est ce que c'est reparti après c'est
moi j'ai juste une question planté j'ai
juste une question posée qui aujourd'hui
en france qu elles courront politique
aujourd'hui en france organise des
ateliers sur une base raciale mais le
problème c'est que vous n'êtes pas assez
pesé dans les faits il va ce qu'ils ont
bien une image du front national c'est
une c'est une manifestation interdite
aux blancs et que si un blanc on le voit
on va les chasser les sujets sains du
military n'a pris organise
l'organisme qui organise ces assises et
qui vont soit mis en place des ateliers
racisées en france où les blancs faim
interdit donc quand elle n'organise pas
des ateliers sur une base raciale et toi
combien tu as à la ramener sur le cas il
ya trois réunions où il ya des gens qui
viennent se plaindre de ce qu'ils ont
peut-être pu vivre tu vois dans le
racisme et que ça les arrange toi toi tu
parles de remplacement toi tu dis tout
le pays devrait être blanc parce que dès
qu'un noir caribous des racines on me
met toi alors merci oui à 37% à 3 103%
ils sont assez d'accord avec les
chroniqueurs jean messia je vous ai
regardé chez pascal praud faire bénir
votre gueule mais je te lis et si moi je
t'écris c'est pas parce que je suis
sympa qu'il faut que tu parles sur les
autres c'est insupportable je parle je
t'ai vu sur les sites qui parlent en vue
sur pascal praud fait extrêmement sur
pascal en gros banon j'espère que je
vais donc voilà pascal tu lui dis quand
il vient chez moi il est sage parce que
moi ça va mal se passer
joli arrêt tout je veux où je veux dire
ce que j'entends me dicte qu'est ce qui
t'a dit de résoudre
merci donc à léonie coulées y trace sur
l'immigration mais l'effort pour prendre
l'argent d'immigration lui c'est ça que
je remarquais ce qui se passe dans un
vestiaire il aime bien cracher sur
l'immigration sur les gens qui ont
réussi par rapport à l'immigration lui
même il est venu en france on
l'accueille à bras ouverts du casque il
fallait ça me l'a demandé la gamme zone
et moi je suis fan a obtenu par le
centre est doté lui dit
parler les gens houssin le monsieur qu à
côté de lui dit qu'il a grandi au
miracle donc au miracle il y avait aussi
de l'immigration je suis posé jamais
construit aujourd'hui ça vous a
construit sa fait de l'homme que vous
êtes ça fait longtemps que vous êtes et
maintenant vous dites faux peut rentrer
faut plus laisser entrer personne
sachez une chose il est beau gars et je
vous laisse une immigration qui viennent
en france pour travailler honnêtement
juste pour avoir une vie meilleure
y'a des mecs je suis d'accord avec vous
cela il faut laisser aux normes h on
contourne mais non tout à lui alors
chacun reste se voir position c'est pas
un parti raciste
merci guillaume qui pour moi a dit des
choses les plus exactes et ensuite
gérard baro dit les à savoir que
effectivement c'est à paris où fx la
partie où effectivement il ya des
racistes mais vu le nombre de personnes
qui composent de ce parti c'est vraiment
des gens qui sont là qui en ont marre
car nos marques de tout cargo qui
profitent de suite c'est trop négligé
car lancement vu personne n'est
satisfait et qui dit pourquoi pas mais
ça c'est vrai c'est vrai ça va être
versé aucune